موسكو يذهب الينا مراسل كاتر مازن عباس
اهلا بك مازن الكرمل اذا يحذر من ان تسليم
كياب دبابات لوبارد سيترك اثرا لا يمحى
على العلاقات مع برلين هل تتخوف موسكو من
ان تتكبد خسائر فدحه في المرحله المقبله
كيف يمكن قراءه هذه التصريحات
العسكريه يرون ان هذه الدبابات قد لا تحدث
تغيرا جوهريا في ميزان القوه العسكريه وان
كان همم يعني امتلاك القوات الاوكرانيه
لها واستخدامها سيؤثر بشكل كبير هو ولكن
همم الجوهره الامر او استياء الكريم لين
يكمن في ان اسرار الغرب على ان ده
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه الحديثه وعمليا هو همم
شال اي مساعد لحياء او استئناف مفاوضات
سلميه بين موسكو
وبالتالي هذه الخطوات عمليا
[موسيقى]
يعني استرجاع الاول ترك الاراضي التي تحتل
اليوم فكيف يمكن التوصل الى حل وسط يعني
ما هي الرؤيه الروسيه في ما تعلق همم
مستقبل هذا همم هذه المعركه او همم السلا
او المباحثات اذا صحت تعبير
او الاتصالات عبر القنوات المختلفه صحيح
ان موسكو لا تزال تتمثل بان هناك همم
اراضي روسيا محتله وهي الاقاليم
الاوكرانيين الاربعه التي تم ضمها للسياده
الروسيه ومن جانب اخر ايضا كيف تتمسك بانه
مفاوضات مع توتنهام مفاوضات يجب ان لا
يكون فيها همم الرئيس بوتن حاليا بالتالي
يعني الطرفان عمليا يترحان شروط همم معقده
للغايه لكن اسكت ترى ان الغرب قادر على
ممارسه الجهود على زيسكي لكي يتخلى عن بعض
من شروطه
وحاول حاول كريم الى حد ماء ان يقدم او
يقوم بخطوات منها
همم من طرف واحد التي اعلنها على بمناسبه
اعياد الميلاد والتي جاءت بناء على نصيحه
او اا اقتراح تركي بهدف اا يقاف العمليات
العسكريه ومن ثم فتح المجال لاطلاق
المفاوضات فلاشه كان التمسك بالمواقف وهي
مواقف الحفظ الاقصى لدى كل من المفوضين
همم ما زال قائما ولكنه قابل للتراجع من
حذف العديد من الخبراء
او لا مؤشر على ان روسيا غيرت همم اهدافها
في حربها ضد اوكرانيا متى عن اعاده ترتيب
الاوراق داخليا هل ما هي حقيقه الوضع داخل
القياده الروسيه خاصه بعد الترتيبات
الاخيره
يا ابني واضح ان موسكو بعد ان فقدت يعني
او لم ترى استجابه
لعمليه استئناف المفاوضات فهي ليس لديها
اي بديل سواء مواصله العمليه العسكريه
ولذلك هناك تغييرات قد جرت بالفعل في
القياده العسكريه واصبح قائد هذه العمليه
وقائد الاركان ما يعطي لهذه العمليه
اولويه رئيسيه لدى السلطات الروسيه
وبالتالي ايضا هناك خطط جديده وتغيرات في
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه تتعلق بمساله انضمام
في فنلندا والسويد الى النيته همم اصبحت
الحدود الشماليه بالنسبه لروسيا ومن وجهه
نظرك يوم الكريم المهدده ايضا بالتالي
هناك تغيرات
تحولت الى حرب حقيقيه مع الغرب الذي يمول
اوكرانيا بمليارات الدولارات المتوقع الذي
يدور في اروقه همم ربما وزاره الدفاع او
القيادات الروسيه
ما يدور في عروقه وزاره الدفاع او
القيادات الروسيه بشكل عام نستطيع الحديث
عنه بانه محاوله
لتنفيذ خطه جديده تستهدف السيطره او
استعاده السيطره على اراضي الاقاليم
الاوكراني الى 4 عسكريه وفي هذا السياق من
التكفيف لعمليات القذف المدفعي والصاروخي
والطيران وايضا اعداد للقوات البريه لكي
تلتحق بربما بيهاجمه واسعه في التوقيت يتم
تحديده من قبل نهايه الاركان للسيطر على
هذه المره بعد قام على المستوى السياسي في
موسكو حتى الان لم تقدم اراء او مقترحات
جديده تختلف نوعيه عن مواقفها السابقه حتى
نستطيع القول بان هناك همم شيء جديد فيما
يتعلق بالخطوات الروسيه نحو التسويات
الازمه وتعتبر موسكو ان المسؤوليه تقع على
عاتق الارض باعتبار ان الطرف الرافضي
للمفاوضات هو اوكرانيا وتحديداسكي الذي
استصدر قرارات
عدم التفاوض مع القياده الروسيه وتحديدا
الرئيس الروسي ولذلك تطالب الغرب ان يلعب
ضد ايضا ترى انبات همم القوات الاوكرانيه
بالاسلحه الحديثه يطيل من امد العمليات
العسكريه وهذا الامر الذي يعني ان الارض
يسرع على او يتمثل بالحل العسكري ولا يفسح
مجالا للحل السياسي شكرا